foreign
hey Josh welcome to the show
all right guys thank you so much for
taking my call and I really want to say
God bless you guys in your ministry that
you do you know you help a lot of people
and uh you know I listen to your show
all the time so I appreciate all of you
guys and and what you do for us thank
you thanks Josh I appreciate that how
can we help
I have kind of a complicated situation
um
I am currently doing uh the baby steps
I'm going through Financial Peace
University I've been doing the every
dollar budget and really been uh hitting
this hard
um I'm married I've been married about
four years my wife is not on board uh
with much of the financial Improvement
um and the complicating thing with that
is
um she keeps you know threatening me
with with divorce and separation
I pay 100 of our bills and I feel almost
like a prisoner in my own home because I
help support not just myself but her and
uh her son I have a 12 year old stepson
and
I work full-time as an ER nurse I travel
for work and I go to school full time
and hoping to change careers so I've
kind of just been at like a just kind of
like a mental breaking point I just
don't know exactly where to go and how
to how to find peace at home and you
know it's uh just something hard to deal
with and I've yeah I listen to you guys
all the time and I thought you would be
a great place to reach out to is the
threatening of divorce over the FPU
steps or is it something else
we're not on the same page with just
about anything financially we've been
separate the entire time we've been
together it's worked for us I know
Rachel you're big on you know having a
combined uh account and the hard part
about
um this situation is uh she has
financially sabotaged herself to the
point where I'm okay with the separation
um you know I want what's best for
everybody but
um she cannot support herself and her
son
okay so let me just yeah put a little
caveat when we do talk about combining
accounts uh it's yeah we think it's very
crucial and when it doesn't happen we
always say there's a reason why it's not
happening and it can be a multiple
reasons you know of they were burned
before in a divorce and they're scared
or they want the control like whatever
there are reasons of why that doesn't
happen and our push is always okay let's
get to the reasons that isn't happening
so for you just in that one example as
you said the reason is is because she
financially has sabotaged herself and I
have she's has she sabotaged herself in
other areas too Josh not just money is
this this sounds like every part of your
marriage you guys just aren't you're not
a fit what what what caused you guys to
get married in the first place was it
different four years ago and it's
changed
um yes from when we first met um
everything was was great I mean we were
really really in love things were great
um we actually met on vacation and it's
just kind of doing a distant dating
thing for a while and as a traveling
nurse I took an assignment out here to
kind of test how things would go it went
very good and then um she went through a
really ugly custody issue with her son
and her ex and I really tried to step up
and you know
be a good man and support her and her
son and I've been doing that and the um
the the difficult part is I didn't find
out about how bad some of the financial
stuff was until after we were married
um and there was a multitude of things
but um I've been trying to support her
and actually in getting into the
financial piece and uh trying to work
through the the Ramsay steps I was like
hey you know we're not on the same page
with a lot of things but let's let's
maybe do this together it might be like
a team building like hey let's get
excited about something let's do this
together and it's just opened up a a can
of worms that I just did not know was
there and you know I I talk all the time
about trying to help her but now I I
can't
and it's literally I okay so not to get
too technical Josh I'm just like the
money side you called for the money so I
know Ken can probably speak into some of
the other parts of this but for the
money specifically what has caused her
to sabotage herself financially is it
that she spends too much is it that
she's not working is it that she yeah
what what is what's the main the main
reasons
okay I'm sorry I know I'm kind of all
over the place no you're fine you're
fine no no you're great
so uh she's actually an accountant
um of all things
um so she struggles with personal
finance where you know
um I know she took out a lien against
her vehicle
um which ended up breaking down it was
about a ten thousand dollar loan against
the car which the car was you know not
salvageable so I ended up having to give
her a down payment for her to get
another vehicle uh I know I found out
that she's taken out loans against her
retirement and her credit score is like
I think it's in the low 500 range so
even though we were trying to go through
this process of you know potentially
separating she can't even get approved
to get an apartment on her own so she's
still living with me because she can't
go out on her own yeah and for the last
six months even though we're basically
separated but living together I pay a
hundred percent of the bills and I just
kind of feel almost like a prisoner in
my own house and you're trying to be a
good Christian man I can't I can't
foreseeably just like hey I'm gonna
break the lease I'm gonna move out you
and your son have to figure something
out well she has a lot she obviously has
a lot of Brokenness in her life and in
her story that is not dealt with and
it's coming out sideways in all these
different ways
um and so have you guys have you guys
done therapy have you guys done marriage
counseling do you have a good church
home do you guys have a pastor do you
have a local therapist that you've seen
at all have you gone that route
we've done couples therapy twice and she
actually even joined it twice like two
sessions
two different no two different
therapists like 20 sessions and then she
actually met with me and one of the uh
Ramsey coaches recently and even that
didn't seem to help okay so Josh do you
want to fight for this marriage or do
you feel like you guys have decided this
deal is done where are you at I believe
it's done I just don't know how to do it
with okay being a good person being a
good man and you know not leave them
high and dry because I just I I have a
hard time with that all right so here's
what I would recommend I I think you
need to go see some counseling on your
end and get as healthy as you can
because you're dealing with a lot and I
want you as clear as you can be with
these decisions you got to make I'd also
like you to see a pastor uh that you
where you go to church and just walk
through what do you feel is your
responsibility uh when this marriage
dissolves but if this thing is over uh
you're not responsible for her and this
kid long term if she's going to keep
making bad decisions so you're gonna
have to walk through all of this and do
what you believe is right